well I said in my review of the giggle
that I would talk about the reveal of
shoy gowa Sonic Screwdriver because yeah
it's pretty dang different from any
Sonic Screwdriver we have ever seen
before on this show and honestly I kind
of like that or at least the idea of it
the specifics of it I'm still getting
used to I kind of just assume that I
will get used to it but I do like the
idea of just coming in with a completely
different design ethos than the Sonic
Screwdriver has ever had especially
speaking of some someone who when we saw
the 14th Doctor David Tenant second go
as the doctor when we saw his Sonic
Screwdriver revealed it was immedately
deliberately but it was very much an
amalgamation of the other ones that came
before it and I really did sincerely
Wonder are we out of new things to do
with this design and maybe we aren't but
it did mean that I'm pretty open to
doing something completely different
which this absolutely does reminds me a
little bit of a Star Trek tricorder to
be honest and I'm kind of here for it